sometimes it's the big things with
Donald Trump sometimes it's the little
things in this case it's a little thing
that gives us insight into Trump's
personality this is so funny
Trump welcomed the president of Finland
Sally
Nene Stowe to the White House and they
did a press conference pretty common
thing they both go out there they take
questions and at one point Donald Trump
sort of goes off script instead of I
think normally like he'll take four
questions and his visiting diplomatic
guests will take four questions or
something like that but Trump goes off
script and he gives the Finnish
president the opportunity to take one
more question
Nene Stowe calls on a female journalist
and Trump seems to think that it's the
same woman who had just asked the
question apparently Trump was not able
to tell the two women apart and if
you're watching this short clip you'll
notice the finished president looking
visibly surprised by this take a look
there might be a couple of more
questions but do you want to take one
more would you want to take one more go
ahead pic please again but you're gonna
give her the same one no she's not the
same yeah yeah the reporter noting there
are lots of blondes in Finland now it's
possible Trump just wasn't paying
attention to who previously asked the
question but if that's the case why say
anything at all and this is just a dumb
little story but it goes along with the
idea that Trump mostly sees women as
ornaments which by all indications is
true it's just an embarrassment in every
way Trump is finding sort of new and
creative ways to be the prototypical
embarrassing American on the world stage
it's never a good look to appear to be
unable to distinguish between members of
X group of people and whether it's this
group alway they're members of this
group look-alike or that group and in
this case you know blonde Finnish women
are not exactly a marginalized group but
Donald Trump's history with women in
general is not particularly good and I
was thinking maybe Trump really doesn't
believe he tried to grope multiple women
even though it was more than a dozen
different women maybe he thought it was
all the same woman because he can't tell
them apart I think the real question is
is this just about women because I don't
know if you would do the same thing to
say to white male reporters from
or is he just so disconnected from
everyone that's around him yeah I think
that's a fair question I think the guy
is just living in his own world
completely and the female reporters for
their sake they didn't really seem
bothered they were probably thrilled to
be out of pee grabbing range if you know
what I mean
going back to that TMZ tape could trump
find Finland on a map like if you put a
map of the world in front of Trump with
no labels on the countries you think you
could point to Finland I think you'd get
the continent right that's all I'm gonna
give him though well that that's
actually funny like I wonder if you gave
Trump an unlabeled map of Asia and said
sir could you point to Finland on this
map would he say no this is a map of
Asia and Finland is in Europe or would
he not even realise that like I
genuinely believe he lacks some of the
most basic knowledge about just
everything that we in a way take for
granted that is part of a normal
education in in some sort of general
sense I don't know if we'll ever find
out but that would be an interesting
little experiment